Mình đã châu diên Kim trận ươi ngày mệt tạm tạm kêu gọi mở giọng nhân trọng năng lực vụ khí hành nhân.
Đông thời chỉ trết của tập trận mi hàng có thể trận ngò trên trang.
Pháp biểu được lươi ra trong chuyển thị sát tạo của chục lớp cho hiôn trên hạm hiện đại nhất của châu diên.
Ông Kim may tỏ hai lòng vì chứ trên hiện đại ngó 2 quân bao gồm trong bị vụ khí có khả năng mạng đầu đại hành nhân đảng dễ tiền lục cái hoạch.
Cùng thời điểm chuyện tham gỗng Kim, Mỹ và hành Quốc đã bắt đầu của tập trận chuông thường niên là trận tự giò ui chi.
Céo dài mấy một ngày với nhiều hạt động mắn đạn thật quy mối lớn.
Cục tập trận năm nay dù có quy mô tương tự nằm ngoại,
sau 2 người trong số buồn mới hạt động và lệ thực liệ đã được giời sáng tháng sau,
theo đề sốt của tập thổ hạt Quốc li nhiên nhau nhằm giảm tăng tham với điều biểun.
Tư khi nhậm chức hồi tháng sau, ông li nữa lực cả thịt quán hệ chỗ kênh,
các vời các tiếp cận tương giản của người tình nhận.
Tuy nhiên, bà chim cho trong em gại ông chim trận ui khẳng định,
cho tiên không của ý định gại thịt quán hệ với xíuun,
đúng thời bắt mò các đề nghị lỗi thuại.